i
no es reacciones en china al golpe de
estado ni a mar más allá de las
protocolarias peticiones ambas partes de
que se esfuercen en reconciliarse y la
exigencia de que el país pueda resolver
el conflicto sin interferencias
extranjeras la prensa china le dedica
muy poco espacio al golpe de estado y se
ha llegado a referir a él con la
eufemística fórmula de una profunda
reorganización del gabinete se aprecia
pues la intención de no tomar partido y
de mantener las excelentes relaciones
con ambos bandos de hecho en la última
visita del ministro de exteriores wang
yi a mianmar hubo reuniones tanto con
representantes del estamento militar
como del gobierno civil el golpe de
estado en un país vecino y con el que
mantiene unos lazos económicos muy
fuertes es una terrible noticia para
china de hecho muchas de sus inversiones
como por ejemplo una mastodóntica presa
sobre el río irrawaddy acumulan años de
retrasos debido a las protestas y los
conflictos étnicos a china también le
incomodan los miles de birmanos que
huyen de la violencia
refugian en la provincia de yunnan es
por todo ello que a china le interesa
que mi mamá recupere cuanto antes la
estabilidad
[Música]
job aiden reaccionó prontamente diciendo
que eeuu quitó las sanciones que tenía
contra mi alma hace una década por los
avances en la democracia pero que este
revés obligará a una revisión de las
sanciones bailén dijo además que eeuu
trabajará con sus aliados en la región y
en el mundo para restaurar la democracia
el estado de derecho y hacer responsable
a aquellos que están impidiendo la
transición democrática por su parte el
secretario de estado
anthony blinken dijo que eeuu se pone
del lado del pueblo y pide la liberación
inmediata de los precios políticos para
medios locales esta es la primera prueba
geopolítica para bailén y sus relaciones
con china ya que en los últimos años
la potencia asiática se ha acercado más
a mianmar de hecho el centro de estudios
estratégicos e internacionales en este
país dice que las eventuales sanciones
por parte de eeuu a mianmar no afectarán
mucho las actividades comerciales y
militares entre los dos países ya que
éstas ya son bastante reducidas
[Música]
esto ha provocado una oleada de
indignación en toda la comunidad
internacional todas las instituciones
europeas han lamentado el nuevo
movimiento del ejército y los países
europeas han advertido que emprenderán
todas las acciones necesarias ante este
retroceso democrático de esta forma la
unión europea podría emprender sanciones
y alinearse de esta forma con eeuu por
su parte el jefe de la diplomacia
europea
josep borrell también ha lamentado
profundamente este golpe de estado y ha
calificado la acción del ejército como
un intento inaceptable de darle la
vuelta al resultado de las elecciones
del pasado noviembre y también del
proceso democrático iniciado en 2011
además se ha pedido la liberación de
todos los detenidos incluidos los de la
nobel de la paz a usa en su chivo
[Música]